dans des
périodes et coll c'est la berceuse des
enfants russe
[Musique]
polina va continuer de la chanter son
petit léo apprendra à la langue aussi la
culture il ne grandira pas en russe
toute la famille s'est exilée à riga les
grands-mères aussi
j'ai fait d'autres pd2 enfin c'était au
lendemain des premières frappes de ce
qu'ils n'avaient même pas le droit
d'appeler une évasion lui craint encore
moins la dénoncer
fink rect
[Musique]
ils ne sont pas à plaindre ils sont
ensemble et ne manquent de rien mais
chacun porte en soi un sentiment de
honte et de responsabilité c'est
horrible
c'est horrible vous sentez coupable
absolument
je n'ai rien fait de mal dont j'ai
participé à toutes les manifs mais ce
n'était pas assez
mischa aussi mais pas cette année il
avait un job de rêve à moscou pour la
compagnie yandex il était heureux malgré
le climat politique tendu
encore plus douloureux c'est d'entendre
vladimir poutine est qualifié de traître
et de dire que leur départ contribuera
finalement à purifie la société russe
manipulation c'est de la manipulation
dit micha c'est sa spécialité
font aussi des
noms
partir plutôt que de tenir tête au
régime plus paraître lac mais c'est la
seule issue possible pour des dizaines
de milles îles russes qui ont pris la
fuite ce qui traverse ici en lettonie
doivent le faire en voiture ou atiq
parce qu'ils
y gagnent du temps et en russe mais
habite en espagne depuis cinq ans il
attend sa grand mère que son père a dû
convaincre de quitter moscou avant qu'il
ne soit trop tard chez
wells elle va pouvoir
jésus christ
il expliquera plus tard en détail
mais d'abord les retrouvailles confuse
épuisé du voyage il dit a dit que
beaucoup de russes en bon nombre
d'ukrainiens qui vivaient aussi en russe
parce que la guerre dit elle finalement
n'est pas une invention
à l'ina est elle aussi le craignait ça
fait quinze ans qu'elle travaille à
moscou comme infirmière russie manières
possibles chauny et surtout elle ne
remettra plus jamais les pieds en russie
avec d'autres femmes elles se dirigent
vers kiev pour offrir des secours est
plongée dans l'horreur dit elle que la
russe infligeant mot paix la guerre aura
changé leur destin
mischa devra trouver du travail pour
obtenir un visa mais c'est rien quand on
se compare au stand by faith in time in
the world is in a few pipeau c'est
d'être grâce à un tuyau
qu'ils ils sont faits si tu en as alors
que tant d'autres ne le sont plus ce
fardeau on va le porter en tout cas moi
jusqu'à la mort c'est sûr mais je pense
que leur génération
plusieurs générations